[Music]
the same rights that give me the right
to be sitting up here saying what i'm
saying now
are the same rights that i am giving to
david irving you do not argue against
deep prejudices what an arrogant
position you're taking some of the most
important ideas
in human civilization
have caused great offense at the time
existing cancer culture may tap right
but it always smashes left
the people who argue that there should
be no platform
and never worried that it might affect
them
[Music]
when i was a student politician um many
many many years ago
when the discussion about no platforming
in a way first began
and then the the left presented it as
being like this um
actual fascists people who kind of you
know march around with uniforms etc are
outside the normal weft of politics
unsusceptible
to debate funny really because it comes
back to what uh yasmin was saying when
she said she wouldn't debate hitler of
course hitler famously didn't debate
anybody
i don't know what history would have
looked like if he had but uh but
famously he didn't he was a kind of no
platformer par excellence in the end he
was the ultimate no platformer
really so the idea was extremely limited
um
but essentially when i thought about it
later and then it's been extended really
and and the issue of offense has
extended it yet further because instead
of it being a judgment about the
efficacy of of a certain type of
politics taking over it becomes a
judgment about the subjective feelings
of people and it is incredibly
problematic to ban things on the basis
of people's subjective feelings because
people have different subjectivities but
it's
a transgender thing incidentally it
illustrates that very well
to to shut down shut down the debate in
your view and there's no question about
it and not only that if you think about
it has another thing the people who
argue that there should be no platform
um
not for offense reasons but for reasons
of let's say normalizing certain types
of speech is a very common expression
now and never worried that it might
affect them
never it's not they're not worried they
might become fascists as a result of it
they're worried that other people will
become fascists as a result of it in
other words these other people they're
making a judgement are the people who
will be affected by this type of speech
the transformation is to anybody i mean
supposing david irving came back and
said i want to speak here and i want to
make the case as i have in the past that
the concentration camps
what happens in the film what happens in
the film denial yeah what happens
he's played by timothy spall and at
certain stages he gives a kind of
creepily good impression of what he's
saying and then he's taken apart uh uh
yeah but they've taken apart partly
because of the brilliance of the
witnesses and the brilliance of the qc
but here we're talking about the
principle of platforming when such
brilliance and may not be available to
deconstruct what he's saying would you
know platform david irving no
no i no i i wouldn't don't platform
david irving but i would very much want
to see a proper contested debate if you
were to have somebody like that involved
or i would want people to understand
what was at stake with it so i might
issue if i try to i might issue youtube
connections to denial so it's a
qualified in a sense it's a qualified
platform it's a platform where you were
built in
certain necessary concerns here's the
problem the same rights that give me the
right to be sitting up here saying what
i'm saying now
are the same rights that i am giving to
david irving in a slightly different
society where people have different
norms and i might want to say what i
want to say about i don't know leading
brexiteers
um
let's suppose that you have a a
nationalist government here in in
britain that says well actually what
you're doing is betraying the country's
interests etc it happens often enough we
don't therefore think that he's an
appropriate person for you have at your
festival and by the way we're going to
get your sponsors to um boycott your
festival uh etc so you don't have the
money to run it if you let him if you
let somebody like him speak so
essentially
those rights applying to irving are also
the rights applying to me yeah but okay
but rights have to have responsibilities
and do you say no they don't you don't
so where did the writers know the idea
that rights have to have
responsibilities it's just not true all
right okay um we want people to take
responsibility it's a fair it's a fair
thing in a fair society to ask but
rights exist independent of
responsibility
my understanding of the theory of
evolution was that much stronger by
knowing what the people who don't
believe it think
if you know only your own position you
do not know it as well as you would if
you knew your
opponent's position here this is jon
stewart mills famous
line from on liberty he who knows only
his own side doesn't even know that
and uh so here i use an example um of
the abortion issue so you know most of
my students at chapman university where
i teach are liberal so they're
pro-choice on the abortion issue
and you know i like to ask them what are
the best arguments that the pro-lifers
have
well frankly most of them have no idea
what the pro-life arguments are
or if they do or if they're pro-lifers
they keep their mouth shut they're
afraid to say something okay not good
not good
so you know i have them um you know
watch like a ben shapiro or a dinish
d'souza video defending the the pro-life
position on the abortion issue
and um
so even if they end up
maintaining their pro-choice position
which i am i'm a pr i'm pro-choice
and um
and but i know what the arguments are
that
conservatives make and that means my
pro-choice position is stronger than it
would have been if i didn't know
what their arguments are so this is this
is jon stewart mills argument for this
you have to know what the other side is
thinking and even if you don't budge an
inch
uh your arguments are much stronger than
they would have been right so
um a couple of issues i give a couple of
examples of this holocaust denial and
creationism these are two communities
i've
interacted with over the decades and
largely debunked largely completely
debunked their claims nevertheless
i learned a lot from them about both the
holocaust and
the theory of evolution but more
importantly what holocaust deniers are
actually arguing
and what creationists are actually
arguing which is not really about the
holocaust or the theory of evolution
so it turns out to be an interesting
thing but in the process of doing
that my
understanding of how the holocaust
happened and why and so forth my
understanding of the theory of evolution
was that much stronger by knowing what
the people who don't believe it
think we could not survive as a society
if we all became freedom of speech
absolutists
if i hear somebody making an
anti-semitic remark which you do more
frequently and i agree is absolutely
shocking and appalling i want to be able
to argue against that i don't want it
driven underground i don't want it to
seem more attractive for whatever
perverse reason people would see it as
more attractive i don't want to hand
power to other people to decide what i
can and can't hear i want anti-semitism
out there so it can be absolutely argued
against you do not argue against deep
prejudices what an arrogant position
you're taking that you have the power to
argue and save us from ourselves it is
not possible to understand the feelings
we're talking here about feeling utterly
i i was assaulted on thursday physically
assaulted these things you see on me all
right the thing that is i'm left with is
why why did he do this what it's the
emotional thing and you do not argue you
cannot
but
there are so many people maybe in this
room who could talk about being
assaulted maybe particularly women what
we've got to say is is that a sufficient
reason for significantly restricting
freedom of speech
and i'm not quite sure i know your
position on this i am not an absolutist
i believe that freedom of speech
always and everybody everybody has a red
line even spiked i have looked at spiked
and i argue with brendan o'neill their
star
almost every other week they have not
crossed certain lines they have not said
anything on their sides that they know
would upset for example
british jewish people they're very
careful they're very very careful
there's a lot of anti-muslim stuff but
there really isn't and what i want to
say is this that we could not survive as
a society if we all became freedom of
speech absolutists or in the public
space restraint and care and kindness is
all i'm saying we need to be kinder and
understand
we have a hierarchy of political
subjectivity so some forms of cancelling
seem to be more visible than others the
council culture practice by the state
and private companies is far more
dangerous to freedom of speech than
students on twitter armed with nothing
but a hashtag righteous indignation and
an nus no platform policy really
existing cancer culture may tap right
but it always smashes left the victims
of really existing council culture are
not relentless cretins like the
eugenicist toby young or the failed
musician lauren fox who are routinely
cancelled upwards into six figure book
deals and tv contracts or given five
million pounds to run as the mayor by
tory party donut jeremy hoskins hoskin
the 1930s british union of fascists made
the same argument that their freedom of
speech was being curtailed oswald mosley
at the same time that his son and the
teddy boys were fire bombing houses in
the area that i live were claiming they
were being deprived of freedom of speech
enoch powell is still hosted by the bbc
to broadcast his rivers of blood speech
nick griffin claimed that the bnp were
the free speech party from bbc question
time if the left really practiced any
meaningful form of cancer culture
alistair campbell who was
proven to be a warmonger would not be
cancelled into good morning britain or
be the advocate for mental health that
he is allowed to be today in fact the
office for students the government put
together the joint committee on human
rights in 2008 did an investigation into
free speech issues in university and
found it did not find the wholesale
censorship of debate which media
coverage had suggested as mike cronin
noted in the 90s fascism did not die in
1945
main
problem that people have is with the nus
and their no platform policy the nus put
it this way we support freedom of speech
through an expression but nus opposes
those who attempt to utilize this
freedom in order to remove the freedoms
of others affording racists and fascists
a platform helps them in their search
for credibility to promote their
messages of hate which in turn can lead
to violence against those they target
the core issue here is that if allowing
freedom of speech to those that
discriminate against people based on
their religion or their race you would
violate the equality act of 2010 but
there's another violation of the
equality act 2010 which is not spoken
about in the context of
cancer culture prevent directly
encourages public sector employees to
surveil young muslim children what that
means is you have children as young as
three having the space under the prevent
program to be questioned by police
without the presence or knowledge of
their parents simply for wearing things
like badges that say free palestine in
fact the problem of council culture
needs to be extended the palestinian
prisoners study center found that from
2015 to 2018 over 500 palestinians were
arrested for posts they made on facebook
and other social media platforms why is
it not a problem for freedom of speech
we have a hierarchy of political
subjectivity in this country so some
forms of cancelling seem to be more
visible than others real council culture
is the well-documented corporate
blacklisting of workers thousands in the
construction industry were blacklisted
merely for talking about health and
safety issues real council culture is
the mi5 vetting prospective employees of
the bbc for if they have members of
their family in the swp
we are not in a situation where we can
talk
in in in pure theoretic theoretics about
what people would do on the left if they
had power the public sphere and the
cultural ambience of our time is so
defined by the influence of
unaccountable offshore capital that the
majority of what we hear and read is
often a reflection of their best efforts
at deflection we today have far more of
a threat to freedom of speech posed by
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg than we
do by any activist on the left though i
would say to the snowflakes on the right
fear not
aristotle died in exile for being a
teacher of alexander the great socrates
was executed confucius died thinking he
was a failure so do not worry your
longevity will be determined by the
strength or the weakness of your ideas
[Music]
same words can be said safely in one
context and not in another
[Music]
the very same words can be fine in one
context and terrible in another
someone has the opinion that the corn
dealers are the starvers of the poor so
he's writing in the 19th century uh and
the opinion is the corn dealers
are hoarding corn when they're hoarding
corn they're putting up the price of
corn and thereby starving the poor who
can't afford the corn and so there's
this debate going on and he's and um
mill says someone writes to their
newspaper uh uh saying the corn dealers
are the starvers of the poor here's why
uh that's one thing that's political
speech but now suppose this person is in
front of the corn dealer's house
uh in front of a angry mob uh who have
their you know i'm exaggerating he gives
more detail that he doesn't give all
this detail but you know you picture the
angry mob with their sort of flaming
torches and their protest banners and
whatnot and there you are with your
megaphone saying the corn dealers are
the starvers of the poor now in that
context uh mill says
it
he says in fact nobody should think he
this person should be allowed to say
that now they might think there are
various reasons why not but one reason
might be in that context is it's because
it would be an incitement to violence
against the corn dealers even though it
doesn't say go and burn down the house
of the corn dealers in that context
saying the corn dealers of the starvers
of the poor to an angry mob is
incitement
now
that's my interpretation of mil it's
certainly no uh controversy there's not
at all controversial that he thinks the
same words can be said safely in one
context and not in another um
but um
what that shows is that what we can
think of words as tools for doing
different things with
freedom of speech is inherently
risky and uh and dangerous and sometimes
unpleasant
well so and the phrase that gets used is
freedom no ifs no buts and that's
one of the slogans that the magazine i
write for spiked online uses which um
makes people feel queasy because they're
they their imagination immediately jumps
to the worst case scenario um and of
course freedom of speech is inherently
risky and uh and dangerous and sometimes
unpleasant and sometimes sick making
because if you do allow people the
freedom to
say and think whatever they like there's
always going to be someone in the room
that comes up with something that is you
know that you disagree with or is even
abhorrent and the important part of why
it's radical to
um to
defend that very uh absolute and
principled view of freedom is because of
the um the the power of actually the the
thought that loki finished on which is
that the longevity of any political
argument has to be based on the strength
or weakness of that argument and i think
the problem today is that we are
actually we we're actually suggesting
that that that process of judgment of
somebody's argument shouldn't take place
i mean there's a really
maybe we can get into this but that i
hate the concept of equality um and the
reason and that's not because i think
that and some people should be more
equal than others or that there should
be some kind of hierarchy but equality
has always seemed like a really lame
marker to me because if you take for
example the um the issue of women's
freedom or women's position in society
women in relation to men
when women and men can be equal we can
be on the same level but that level can
be
a really bad quality of life that
equality can be really poor that can we
can both be equal right down here but if
you're championing freedom instead of
equality what you're saying is the sky
is the limit and i think the radicalness
of that demand is in is is the reason
why it's rejected today is because
there's a deep misanthropy and mistrust
of people
freedom of speech
means nothing if it is not the right of
the person who thinks differently to
express their point of view
i don't think there is a right to not be
offended
and if you look throughout history some
of the most important ideas
in human civilization
have caused great offense at the time
so for example the ideas of galileo
galilei
charles darwin
karl marx sigmund freud they all caused
huge offense in their time
but they were important
valuable ideas and even if you disagree
with them those were ideas that ought to
be heard debated and discussed
um
the problem is now that this idea that
you've caused me offense
now provokes reaction no platform safe
space
and that does in my view diminish the
opportunity and exercise of free speech
and open debate which are vital
for a free and open society
i'll give you a few examples
of course we know that racism is wrong
but i think about the example of an
overseas student who came to study at a
british university
who in a debate used the term color
now
in the current context that is deemed an
inappropriate even offensive word to
describe non-white people
but this student didn't know that
in her home country that was perfectly
okay
yet she was denounced condemned
and vilified
because she used this bad inappropriate
word
um
another example in the whole debate
about the black lives matter movement
there are disagreements within that
movement over tactics
and the way in which the movement is
organized has led to some people
being denounced as crypto uncle toms
because they haven't conformed to a
particular interpretation
of what the black lives matter movement
should be doing
to me the zealotry
dirty tricks
it's got echoes of
you know
the worst kind of excesses of left-wing
sectarians
these people pose as being on the left
well
my version of between politics has got
to do with false allegations
with
abuse
and so on
in fact
you know i take
my cue from german communist rosa
luxembourg
you argued against lenin
that
freedom of speech
means nothing
if it is not the right of the person who
thinks differently to express their
point of view
so she argued for open debate
within the communist movement and beyond
as the way to get the right
answers to get the right strategy to
challenge ideas
to question ideas to open
the party to
dissenting alternative points of view
she found that she felt that was
fundamental
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
[Music]
you